it has been a violent month in jerusalem
and the occupied west bank but another
all-out conflict has so far been avoided
for now
the story of hussain is like the story
of so many palestinian towns and
villages on one side it is enclosed by
the 25-foot wall that divides israel
from the west bank on another side just
up on that hill is an israeli settlement
built on palestinian land because of
this residents of hussein say they feel
surrounded and trapped
on a recent sunday morning during
ramadan gada sabatine was shot dead by
an israeli soldier at a roadblock in the
village
the idf told us the soldiers followed
protocol by firing warning shots and
shouting at her to stop
no weapons were found on her body her
family say that the lawyer the mother of
six in her mid-forties was murdered
and uh there is no way to express my
grief god his mother told me she was
well-mannered respectful and polite she
was top of her math class at bethlehem
university
would the soldier have done this to his
mother or sister she asks
four days later in the same spot in the
same palestinian village
sixteen-year-old kusai hum ramra was
also shot dead by israeli soldiers
so you've got one two
three four and this one here five five
six
seven seven eight yeah eight bullets
was in the local mosque for evening
ramadan prayers when he heard the
gunfire
and they didn't allow the ambulance or
anybody
to give any assistance for him so he he
died here yeah he
died right here yeah
these killings are both being
investigated by the idf and they have
added to the feeling of oppression and
hatred here
it has also been a violent month for
israel in late march in early april 14
people were killed in four separate
terror attacks
in response israeli forces have been
carrying out operations in the west bank
all month this was in the town of janine
earlier in the week
the idf is taking a dual approach at the
same time where they want to combat
terrorism they're also offering a policy
of distinction where they want to make
sure that the fabric of of quality of
life for regular uh palestinians for the
innocent palestinians can go on and
carry on their normal lives and we've
seen this this week as well with with
tens of thousands of palestinians coming
in and being able to to pray at the uh
at the mosque during ramadan so it's
kind of a dual approach from the idf
but that is not the perception amongst
many palestinians
in fact in busan in jerusalem and
elsewhere in the west bank there is now
talk of another uprising
and they say it will be bloodier than
anything that has gone before
that might not happen this year
but the past month
has only made it more likely
alice ivanka sky news in jerusalem